so now they're blaming antidepressants
and marijuana cannabis for the mass
shootings that the united states is
plagued with that's where the american
right wing
now is so let me show you something
interesting before we dive into these
latest claims here are previous stories
that i that i've done over the years
covering
the different things that the right is
blamed for mass shootings and notice
what's missing from this list so this
this is over the last many years on the
show
fox news blamed masks like coveted masks
abortion
and woke for mass shootings in the
united states
they've previously blamed joe biden for
mass shootings
they've blamed rap music video games and
coveted lockdowns
for
mass shootings right winger brian fisher
and fox news blamed the fact that some
churches ban guns
for mass shootings in churches not long
ago and famously cartoonishly ted cruz
republican senator from texas blamed
doors for mass shootings here's one from
the archives way back in 2011
a wacky arizona sheriff
blamed rhetoric
for a mass shooting okay
notice that guns are completely missing
the guns are what
the shootings are done with a gun
but they never talk about guns they talk
about everything other than guns and now
it's marijuana and it's anti-depressants
laura ingram on fox news talking about
this we talked about this a little bit a
couple of weeks ago and she's still at
it she did this again this week based on
the latest shooting in highland park
illinois
but instead of selling fear and division
wouldn't it be nice if we all began to
focus on solutions don't people want
solutions i suggest they do
now on the mass shooting in illinois
indications are that robert cremo was a
regular pot user now one look at him and
to the untrained eye he looks like a
complete psychotic you ever seen anyone
looking like him now the the his
appearance
we don't yet know but there are many
medical professionals actually
speculating that his physical appearance
is indicative of of a syndrome
uh
let's just leave it there so the point
is if you want to look at the physical
appearance there's definitely lots of
questions raised by the physical
appearance but the marijuana piece seems
sort of like neither here nor there and
what can regular pot use trigger in
young men in particular
psychosis and other violent personality
changes not everyone but a significant
percentage okay so it is not a
significant percentage and we actually
have good studies on this we have actual
peer-reviewed research it is true
that some studies have found
a slightly higher likelihood of violent
behavior among cannabis users but
haven't been able to establish any
causality at this point it hasn't been
established that cannabis makes people
who were not already predisposed to
violence to be any more violent and
lastly there's no evidence i was able to
find that cannabis use makes people more
likely to commit crimes even if some
criminals are high on cannabis at the
time that they commit a crime there's
been no causal relationship that's been
established and maybe most notable i
mean sometimes we just have to say does
this pass the sniff test the prevalence
of cannabis use is way higher in a ton
of countries that have almost no mass
shootings look at pot use in the south
american country of chile
almost no shootings
look at canada
third in the world in terms of
uh per capita cannabis use
almost no shootings israel
super high cannabis usage almost no
shootings you get the idea
so that's uh
cannabis
now antidepressants this is another one
this is a recycling of something that
others have talked about alex jones used
to talk about ssris ssris are selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors these are
often prescribed for anxiety and or
depression some of these have been
around at least 50 maybe even more like
70 years
very very safe and well studied class of
drugs marjorie taylor greene radical
republican congresswoman from georgia is
now on the ssri bandwagon she tweeted
quote
when are we going to have an honest
conversation about drug abuse
mental illness and ssris
deadly side effects are we really going
to keep pretending
or covering for big pharma
because i'm absolutely done with the
political plays on this bs
there is no evidence that ssris cause
people to be violent now this requires a
little more thinking and thinking is not
a common
it's not a prevalent commodity it's not
an abundant commodity in general and
particularly among the american right
one of the considerations is
people
predisposed to violence
might be getting prescribed the ssris
that's not evidence that the ssris
caused the violence but it's a potential
reason for why violent people might be
on ssris that's one thing
the second part of it and this is a
really big issue
lots of young people prescribed ssris
aren't actually taking them or taking
them as prescribed
there's a study
and you
are you guys willing to think with me
here because otherwise we're in trouble
there's a study that found a small
association not a causation a study
found an association between people 18
to 24
on ssris and violence and that
association doesn't exist for those 25
plus so you look at people 25 plus on
ssris no association between ssris and
violence you look at 18 to 24 there's a
small association between being on ssris
and violence association not causation
and the study
recognizes the study is based on what
people are prescribed
not based on what people are taking
the 18 to 24 group
might be more likely to not actually
take the medication that they're
prescribed
and if they took the medication it might
reduce their propensity for violence
this is the exact same thing that
happened with now i don't remember if it
was with ivermectin or with
hydroxychloroquine there was this brazil
it was ivermectin a brazilian quote
study
supposedly quote found
that people given prophylactic
ivermectin were less likely to get
coveted or to become seriously ill from
covid and then the study was eventually
debunked and shown to be a very poor
study because it wasn't a controlled
study of any kind there was a community
where um
ivermectin was just handed out
and there was no actual way to know did
the did anybody actually take the
ivermectin did the people who didn't get
sick were they actually taking the
ivermectin if i were to just go into a
neighborhood and hand out some
medication
and i don't actually know if anybody
took it and even if they say they took
it did they actually take it the way it
was prescribed and then i make some kind
of conclusion from that it would be very
bad science and similarly the one study
that found this small association among
18 to 24 year olds between violence and
ssris we don't know whether actually
they were taken we just know that they
were prescribed so it's more junk
science and notice they will throw
anything they can at the wall
see what sticks
other than saying we've got to deal with
guns